これじゃドクター
初めてこのキャラの存在を忘れていましたチャンスベアが世の中にはたくさんのうちつ
あることがあります何が好きつかただ今お寿司
カレー級のピザ彼のピザピザピザ19-10+して理論プロペラブレード bamboo
blade 嬉しいですよね
私ロニーユーチューブを見て研究いたしますで直物を検分
ちょっと美味しくなるそういうものがあるみたいなんですけどその検証を助ける私が今
話を通している研究は必ず成功するはず
名付け流動を天ぷらにすると同じで美味しい設置だってと品ドクターはじめ流動が
大好きな大平思ってるくらい
江戸出るぐらいに好きなんて私流のが大好きなんて
大事な旧道をもっと美味しくなると売れている店舗にする
と史上最高に美味しいんじゃないかというふうに一人そうな検証を今からん
深夜
産地と工夫してしっかりと牛道の天ぷらを作る和夫
ちゃんと柔道店分離する工夫をしていこうと思う
井戸あーあず使うならこちら柔道において大切なのは流動が固形ではありませんお米が
牛肉からのだし汁によって液状化せしまっているので流動屋さんの牛タンとは違って
コンビニの牛丼はお肉の部分と米が別々になっているのでエンプラが完成してから汁を
かけますのでまずは nikko
乗せるだけ
こうすることによってこの半谷騎乗勝島ゲーになるエキスを鑑定した天パに後出かける
こと可能となった戦災的なアイディアだろう素晴らしい涙が出ちまうぜ
今からがまた工夫が必要ですさあラップを使います
このままぶっこんでもう編ブラにしてる間に流動の答えが仏壇してしまうので1回声に
出します
美しい一度こいつらを一つにするべきだこれは何度は一つかたまにします
矢部さんとまんねーおおきにこれで完成だ天ぷらのもととなる牛丼の方まで課税した後
挙げるのみ
これは何だことあ
[音楽]
大丈夫お前が固まっていればいいさあやっていこうきっとこれがあれば的天ぷら粉水を
泡立て器でよく混ぜますそう簡単だ
まずは斜めに燃える
ぺてぃく雨なんかもドクターはじめのキャラが自分でもよくわかんねんはちょっとまだ
実験系があったらドクターはずに行ってきますね
いざ出陣
[音楽]
ポケットだけに加熱しておこう
さあ作っていこうまぁだいたいでしょ
[音楽]
席料ってのは難しいんだよなます
玉がなくなったからだいたい良いんじゃねぇちょっと入れていきましょうまでもいい
いけるぞ早速衣をつけていきましょう開けた瞬間数えたりしない
お客計を持って音響拠点を直ポケー
いい感じではないでしょうかいげループスあったゴールを決めるのは行ってこい
はいっ
あっひげそうなくらいパンのここしかない
ああ
曲はパーサーンってくるぞ
pou dou dou
ten
すーっ
運ミステイク
[音楽]
てきたはいというわけで完成しました天ぷら牛丼です
惜しかった布絵されない海あそこであのボールの角中崩さなかったループって時があっ
たんですけどもそこでボール場だった旧と思われたことによって断片的な部分にも衣が
厚く塗ってさらにサクサク感がアップしたという可能性もありえ
つまり遂行です死ぬ声さえないか言えないかこれで美味しければいいんですが全然に
とっておいたエキスをかけましょうもうこれはタウン天ぷらです
これはついの出かけた瞬間とろけてしまいますよユニークがビーフジャーキーみたいに
咲 saki しちゃってますね部分的に咲 saki してで美味しそうですでは
いただきます
まず
[音楽]
me
バッハ
まずいというか店プラザなければ美味しいなもん
ホットドックも行ってみよう
あーナメクジみたいになっちゃったロボがポロポロずるんですけど食べてみましょう
まあホットドッグは本当にはやもうマスタードが立って皆さん是非天ぷらにするときは
ホットドッグをやってみてはいかがでしょうか
柔道はマジ
[ __ ]マズ